[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to cbs mornings we now turn
to margaret brennan's exclusive
wide-ranging cbs news interview with
vice president kamala harris the vice
president spoke with margaret one day
after senator joe manchin said he
couldn't vote for president president
biden's build back better plan a major
setback for the president's domestic
agenda listen to what the vice president
said about that
do you feel that senator manchin is
playing fair with you i mean he went on
television and said no pretty
definitively i think the stakes are too
high for this to be in any way about any
specific individual we have to you know
one of the things the 50 50 senate
though so it is
the stakes are so high
i refuse to get caught up in the what
might be personal politics
when the people who are
waking up at three o'clock in the
morning worried about how they're going
to get by
could care less about the politics of
d.c so you don't feel betrayed
no i don't feel i don't have any
personal feelings about this this is
about let's get the job done and talk
with families who say i can't afford
to do the basic things that i need to do
as a responsible adult like care for my
children care for my older parents or
afford to get life-saving medication
like insulin we have to do that without
center mansion you don't give up that's
how we do it
margaret brennan who's moderator of face
the nation ncbs news chief foreign
affairs correspondent joins us right now
good morning margaret now the vice
president says they are not giving up on
the president's agenda um do they need a
back-up plan to the buildback better
plan
or rebuild build back better as senator
joe manchin said nate yes well the vice
president in our interview was very
clearly trying to lower the temperature
because the reality of the situation is
that they cannot afford to be angry for
very long unless the white house can
peel off the support of
some republicans they need senator joe
manchin they need his vote to get
virtually anything done in a 50 50
evenly divided senate they need all
democrats and it is not a good look
after eight months of infighting for
this to be front page news that they're
having problems wrangling their own
party so they need senator manchin to
change the tax laws immigration climate
and voting rights and that is another
topic that i spoke with the vice
president about at length she feels very
passionately
about trying to pass two voting rights
laws at the federal level because of
what's happening in at least seven or 18
states where they're changing um how to
cast votes so she emphasized that as
really the biggest threat to our country
on the national security front nate and
i thought that was very interesting at
the integrity of our democracy at itself
so i suspect you will hear about
potential changes to how the senate
votes and and their rules of engagement
well she's certainly being the grown-up
in the room and saying this isn't
personal because i hear a lot of
democrats when it comes to joe manchin
they're very er very angry and i hear a
lot of why
why i ought with him so it's very
interesting that they're taking that
tactic it's probably the best thing to
do at this point i know you must have
talked to her about omicron and what the
white house how they feel about it how
they're dealing with it are they ready
for it because it is a mess
it is scale and and we know that it is
the virus that determines the path of
the economy it may also determine the
political fate of this white house so uh
on camera and the the vice president was
very clear that they believe they are
prepared for this
but and our health system is prepared
but as you know the president is going
to be making this address to the public
today to try to do a little bit more
where whether it's at home testing or to
try to reassure the public because they
know they cannot afford economically or
politically to go into another lockdown
and that is another topic we talked
about you know on the back end of this
looking at the economy
will they need another rescue package
and that brings you back again to the
need to have some full support in
congress
because
right now
price inflation is going to continue
yeah margaret looking overseas there is
the possibility of a war between russia
and ukraine and there's a question mark
about how involved the u.s would become
if that happened you asked the vice
president about all of that let's listen
and then talk about her response
there are a hundred thousand russian
troops on the border with ukraine
are we going to see a hot war in europe
in the next few weeks
well we are
having direct conversations with russia
with the president as you know met
recently virtually with
putin
and
we are very clear
that
that russia should not
invade
the sovereignty of ukraine that we must
stand up and we are standing up for its
territorial integrity
we are working with our allies in that
regard and we've been very clear that we
are prepared to issue sanctions like
you've not seen before does that mean
sanctioning vladimir putin directly i'm
not going to talk about specific
sanctions but we are making that clear
to him and we are in direct
conversations
interesting margaret what'd you think of
that response
well financial sanctions have not
stopped vladimir putin before so this
seems to be a very direct threat in a
different nature from this white house
but tony i continue to hear from u.s
officials that they are very concerned
that vladimir putin will take some
action whether it's a destabilized
destabilizing cyber attack
or it's actually moving those 100 000
troops across the border so we are not
out of the woods the white house again
made an offer to continue uh diplomacy
with moscow the vice president is never
short of words that's for sure margaret
thank you